[Music]
you're a big halloween fan i think we
actually talked about this uh once years
ago you love halloween you take it very
much my favorite holiday absolutely and
you like to make your own costumes yeah
it doesn't feel right unless i kind of
do it myself that's true good for you
that's the spirit of creativity what
kind of costumes are we talking about i
mean well my rule in general so i don't
drive myself crazy is that i have to
conceive of
and execute the entire costume all on
the day of halloween really i don't do
anything i don't do any planning i come
up with something or like oh look i have
a fork i'll make something out of this
and like so the costume could end up
being really brilliant or horrible and
sometimes it is horrible sometimes it
consists of you know a fork tape to some
newspaper that's wrapped around my head
and i like and people are like what are
you and i'm like i have a fork on my
head you know happy halloween that's the
best i can do it's a fork happy
halloween
deal with it i i went through a series
where i was just colors like one year i
was blue and then the next year i was
red it's you can go to kmart and just
buy everything there that you can find
this one color and put it all on and
paint your face and then you say i am
red i'm red and that's it it tends to be
a conversation stopper yeah which
slam no candy uh all right we have with
this photo i don't know if this is for
halloween this is you in a french maids
app that was last halloween yeah that
was it uh thank you
very nice i sort of broke my own rule
because i was doing a show that
halloween i did i do this thing called
hit record and we had a show on
halloween i was in new york and uh i i
came out as a as a french maid very nice
yes thank you i've always wanted to wear
that outfit just i haven't thought of a
an excuse yet
especially not outdoors uh
i want to ask you about a movie that i
am i'm obsessed with which is the
lincoln movie that uh that i know that
you are in yeah it's steven spielberg's
uh
take on abraham lincoln i heard you're
into the civil war period very into this
period and uh and of course daniel day
lewis in this film plays lincoln you
play his eldest son robert robert um
what's it like i'm just daniel day-lewis
is such a fascinating character to me
what was it like to act with him what's
his process like because i've heard his
method did he become lincoln he kind of
did i mean he's not silly about it you
know he knows that you're on a movie set
and whatever but he does uh he does stay
like talking in that voice he spent a
year coming up with how he wanted the
voice to sound and he doesn't i never
heard his voice and i never called him
daniel until i was lucky enough to be
there on the last day of shooting and so
i got to watch him shed
the character that's so interesting to
me so he would talk as lincoln and you
would all address him as what mr
president steven spielberg yes he'd be
like mr president can you take a step to
the left yep
i would just say sir because he was my
dad
right yeah that's fascinating to me yeah
well i mean
again he's not like silly about it right
you know he'll he'll you know chat or
make jokes in between takes or whatever
but but as lincoln kind of kind of like
yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't want to
like go up to him and be like
you know oh did you see uh you know did
you see the avengers or whatever like
you know he wouldn't probably what is
this a video
that's exactly how he sounds that is all
i'd be doing the whole time i'd be like
look an airplane
no
what witchcraft is this but uh but no
like if you if there's like a painting
on the wall or something he'd be down to
talk like oh look at that you know or
something
he wasn't silly about it but he
definitely
he's really focused and you are going to
play uh your when the movie comes out
you will be his eldest son robert he had
a strained kind of relationship well he
was kind of an absent father yeah and
that's that's that's a cool thing about
this movie is you know abraham lincoln
is such an icon in american culture up
on mount rushmore on our five dollar
bill we we turn him into this hero this
kind of absolute angel and he was a
human being like every other human being
and i i really admire stephen for taking
the approach with this movie and and
painting him as a human being somebody
who had to make compromises who was
being told that he was a bad person from
all sides of the spectrum and all he was
trying to do i mean he the the movie is
about the month
leading up to the passing of the 13th
amendment that banned slavery uh and he
had to make all sorts of moves and do
all sorts of like questionable things
yeah to pass uh
how to make a lot of compromises yeah
and uh and his own as you said his own
personal life or relationship with his
eldest son not perfect yeah exactly